more Babylon 5
movies
animated and maybe js's live action show
is in more Peril than we realized oh
crap welcome to sidre your Sci-Fi TV and
movie
[Music]
channel so I am here on my holidays but
I'm just been having a little bit of a
chat with somebody that I know very well
over at the Warner Brother Studios and
they've been telling me that there's
been a lot of conversations going on
over there at the moment about what to
do with Babylon 5 now I have to start
the conversation by saying apparently no
final decision has actually been made on
the live action TV series
but there is a definite feeling over at
Warner Brothers that the live action
reimagining might not succeed they have
been trying to find a partner to produce
a TV show with somebody that would
actually buy the show they were looking
at Amazon Apple Etc and I reported to
you guys recently that Netflix was
actually the most likely new home for
the Babylon 5 reimagine series I was
there I was there at the dawn of the
third
age but all of the studios and partners
that they've been talking to have all
raised the issue that when they have
asked people about the new Babylon 5
reimagine series that J M kazinski the
original creator has been talking about
now for nearly two years a lot have been
saying they don't want a new version of
Babylon 5 that in fact there's nothing
wrong with the original it is perfection
and why mess was something that
basically is perfect a lot of the fans
are saying look we don't want remakes
and hard reboots a continuation if you
could do that that would be great the
problem is at the end of season five of
Babylon 5 JMS kind of cut the ropes and
made it very very difficult for a
continuation ever to happen babyon 5 is
The Last of The Babylon stations it says
it in the credits and we see Babylon 5
getting destroyed we see a lot of things
like how president sedan's life ends etc
etc we got told an awful lot of the
story there isn't really anywhere for a
continuation well unless it's not going
to be aboard Babylon 5 to go and JMS has
already talked about this repeatedly on
Twitter saying basically look nobody
wants to buy Babylon 6 or Babylon 4
prequel they want to buy Babylon 5 so a
new show has to be based aboard the
space station so what could we do
instead well I'm being told that Warner
Brothers animation is already working on
another animated movie and this will be
set within the original series universe
so like how the road home was set with
Sheridan and Sinclair and all of those
other characters that we love jakar EX
ET replacing some of the actors that
have passed away with new actors and
getting as many of the original actors
back as possible there is a possible
future for several of these animated
movies and as I said the first one is
already having the initial work done for
me I've only watched the road home very
recently actually in the last couple of
weeks and I absolutely have to say I
adored it I thought it was a bit fluffy
in places the storyline got a bit or
dare I say
preachy um JMS isor been very strong
with the spirituality side of things and
you know watching Babylon 5 back in the
day religion and things and spirituality
were important parts of many the story
lines it got a bit like that in places
them asking why a certain thing's
happening rather than you know just
actually focusing on a really
interesting story I mean jakar in the
end of it basically is like God which
was a little
strange but I mostly loved the movie I
actually have to say particularly the
battle sequences against the Shadows
were great and if they're going to do
more animated movies I say do more of
that do more of sort of the Shadow War
let's see more of it I really loved how
um the first of the Babylon 5 sort of TV
movies was a flashback we went back into
time and actually saw s Sheridan
fighting the mimari I'd love to see more
of that as well and that is the nice
thing about
animation yes some of the actors have
passed away but they can respectfully be
replaced and the rest of the actors are
much much older so do it with animation
where you can actually get around a lot
of those
problems and we saw it in the road home
they did it very very well
so as I say just to recap it does look
like the original Babylon 5 plan to
completely remake and reimagine the
series led by JMS still is in trouble
the theory was that they could get away
with it if the original filmmaker J M
cinski was still in charge but it would
seem no the animated movies it looks
like we are going to be getting at least
two more I should say depending on how
the second one does I imagine but work
on that apparently has already begun and
J M cinski apparently is being tapped up
for a script as we speak if it's not
already actually being
done so when will we hear about this
well I suspect it'll be very much like
the road home that we won't actually get
any official announcement from Warner
Brothers until the project is virtually
done so what eight nine months away but
then will get a release within a couple
of months of that why did they do that
because they want people to be excited
about it they did exactly the same with
the road home they keeped it kept it
very secret nobody knew they were doing
an animated movie nobody I actually
heard about six months before it was
officially announced that they were
doing an animated movie and I didn't
believe it so that's how well a secret
they kept
it but if we get a couple of more
animated movies I really want to see
something maybe a little less fluffy a
little less spiritual there I say and
just as
thought-provoking but the battle
sequences in the animated movie were
really really excellent I want to see a
lot more of that because I've got to say
I'm just a sucker for a space battle but
guys what do you think is the Babylon 5
reimagined series that JMS has been
pushing so hard for for two years nearly
does that seem like something you'd want
to see do want to see that show
reimagined with new special effects a
new story by JMS who has had a couple of
decades since to really hone his
thinking hone his writing as well he
basically said this would be a project
of one of his favorite projects but with
a mature head on his shoulders
completely reimagines from the boots up
is something he said more than
once but maybe perfected I don't know I
think it's pretty damn perfect to begin
with or do you think no leave it alone
if they can't do a continuation don't do
anything whether JMS is in charge or not
I'd love to know exactly what you think
get in the
comments if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to
patreon.com where most of our new videos
do Premiere first and you get to see
them without the adverts for small
contribution each month that really
supports Channel you even get a free
gift can't say further than that also go
to
s.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles on some of our
videos and we try to add a little bit
more information for you to digest so go
please check it out as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time